una piccola endovena ad arte magari
spero qui dietro avrete un po delle mie
immagini realizzate negli ultimi 20 anni
mi sono sporcato la camicia prendendo un
po d'acqua partite allora volevo dire
l'arte in realtà ha sempre osservato la
natura magari con occhio diciamo
estetico ha ridisegnato ha disegnato
diciamo l'ambiente quello in cui viviamo
e di fatto qual è realmente però il suo
impegno nei confronti di quelli che sono
le problematiche sia della biodiversità
che magari dell'ecosistema non ci sono
state diciamo dei passaggi molto diciamo
così rivoluzionari come l'evento della
fotografia in cui ha cambiato
completamente la visione di quello che
il mondo
finiva diciamo un mondo tradizionale
legato diciamo all'aspetto artigianale
della decorazione dell'abbellimento e
della ritrattistica e veniva il problema
che fare da quel momento in poi quindi
nasceva un'arte di concetto di pensiero
è qui che nascono le varie vari
movimenti no dall'impressionismo
dall'arte moderna e così via per ogni
volta che nell'arte viene detto qualcosa
di fatto non è ripetibile
se non si può parlare di plagio del già
detto è di fatto diciamo un mattone
senza un reale dialogo tra tra i vari
artisti è un mattone per costruire
diciamo quello che si intende per arte
l'arte un po come la gravità se ne
percepisce la presenza ma non la si vede
e si tenta di dare ogni volta un volto
un volto a questa a questa entità che ci
accompagna da sempre l'arte dicevo prima
osserva la natura la imita poi mi rendo
conto effettivamente che il mio lavoro è
legato molto alla
la vita alla natura all'ecosistema sono
vegetariano animalista convinto non ho
diciamo una grossa partecipazione nelle
manifestazioni legate a
l'ambiente però il mio lavoro divulga
abbastanza il senso del bello e
dell'estetica e dell'armonia quello che
l'arte la bellezza dove una realtà di
mostrare diciamo nel mio lavoro
queste opere come dicevo prima sono
lavori degli ultimi dieci anni
poi magari ognuno ovviamente avrebbe
bisogno di una spiegazione più
approfondita perché poi anche le opere
vivono anche e vengono ospitate negli
spazi ovviamente adatti viste su
internet
ovviamente hanno un consumo più più
rapido vista in una galleria non
contemplazione più lenta e più
suggestiva vista e magari in un contesto
come questo se ne dà sempre un altro un
altro effetto un'altra lettura in questo
caso un acquario con degli uccellini e
dei pesci che convivono nello stesso
ambiente no quindi è una vasca diciamo
inserita all'interno un abolire inserita
interno dell'acquario dove convivono
questi animali simili di colore e simili
simili di misura nel vabbè questo
ovviamente è piazza del duomo di milano
in cui graf e con la tecnologia col
computer ho tolto il duomo
quindi risulta una piazza presente dai
1.300 oggi con la sua assenza in qualche
modo si sente la sua presenza nonostante
diciamo non non c'è
tornando questo per esempio un altro
lavoro legato a alla crisi greca in cui
crollando
crollando diciamo in questo caso la
grecia crollando i monumenti crollando
la crisi che sta attraversando da questa
rottura che è una sorta di minerva nel
suo nuovo nuovo come cellula e quindi
una forma di possibilità di speranza
ecco l'arte sa anche essere molto
provocatoria molto critica e quindi in
qualche modo poi dialogare su quelli che
sono eventualmente le problematiche che
l'uomo man mano si pone si pone che sono
le problematiche quelle dell'arte quindi
doveva l'arte l'arte contemporanea e
dove stiamo andando noi perché questo
caso abbiamo qui l'africa che a forma di
teschio non tanto per la tragedia che ha
attraversato il continente quanto magari
per l'aspetto antropologico in cui hanno
individuato che diciamo l'uomo si è
evoluto in una zona subsahariana più o
meno nell'africa e quindi realtà i
reperti ritrovati
diciamo le ossa ritrovate documentano
diciamo della nostra evoluzione quindi
una sorta di tributo a quello che l'uomo
poi andrà a colonizzare quindi le radici
sono in africa il tronco potrebbe essere
in europa e i rami in tutto il mondo poi
questo è un altro lavoro legato alla
natura in cui in una teca galleggia
questo corpo che viene trasportato
sa verso dove quando sono stato invitato
da tor de biase effettivamente pensavo
ci fosse un errore visto che mi occupo
di immagine di arte contemporanea invece
qui ho sentito molti tecnici che in
realtà si occupano poi di dettagli
proprio legate alla natura la via al bio
vero e proprio e invece credo che la
biodiversità un argomento che comunque
riguarda tutti ci riguarda tutti e
nessuno nessuno è esente
nessuno è esente quindi la
partecipazione può essere in diversi
modi lo è già in qualche modo in cui
l'educazione gradualmente avanza tipo
soltanto la raccolta differenziata tipo
la sensibilizzazione sul vegetariano si
prevede che per esempio diventeranno i
nostri futuri figli probabilmente
vegetariani probabilmente legato sia
alla crisi
quella che stiamo attraversando
economica probabilmente ma sia per un
fatto di coscienza c'è chi è vegetariano
leggevo che sono di vegetare c'è uno in
realtà si è in grado di ammazzare il
proprio animale se lo può anche mangiare
io non ho questa capacità perché una
forte empatia nei confronti degli
animali e quindi di fatto per quanto la
carne possa piacermi diciamo rinuncio
rinuncia a mangiarla
credo che che ci possa essere una una
come dire una collaborazione sia tra
l'aspetto propositivo sia dall aspetto
formale e l'aspetto del risultato del
risultato è quello che potrebbero essere
eventualmente le conseguenze di un di un
di un di un processo di un processo
dialettico che effettivamente si
sviluppa in tanti parti del mondo mi
diceva prima autour de blasi che di
dedic se ne sono 20 in italia 2000 e nel
mondo quindi eventualmente una realtà
che piano piano capillarmente cerca di
sensibilizzare e di creare uno scenario
è un mondo migliore per quelli che sono
eventualmente le condizioni in cui
stiamo attraversando sia a livello
diciamo dell'ecosistema e sia quello
della qualità della vita l'arte in
realtà come dicevo prima non ha una
forma non ha un volto ma ogni tecnologia
del momento cerca di fatto di definirla
una volta si usava molta pittura
scultura poi dicevo prima con la
fotografia è nato il concetto il
pensiero col moderno si sono rotte le
tele poi con il computer è stata
un'altra grandissima rivoluzione in cui
forse le gallerie stesse diventano degli
spazi lo diciamo non frequentati e con
la rete è molto più capillare quindi
cambiano ogni volta diciamo anche gli
scenari della proposta di quello che
fare arte no
l'arte stabilità stabilito che il brutto
è bello è che ognuno è un artista
differenza tra chi lo è e chi non lo è e
che l'artista si prende la briga di
farlo di esercitare il fatto di fare
l'artista no l'arte può essere un lavoro
l'arte non è un lavoro perché in realtà
non c'è una domanda
l'artista crea un'opera e si ha la
capacità di divulgarla scusa gianni
prima del cavolo in questo caso voglio
dire è un lavoro di vent'anni fa
interrompo discorso di prima per
spiegare solo sto lavoro c'è stata la
cosa di chernobyl esplosione della
centrale in cui si era parlato che tutti
gli ortaggi sarebbero stati contaminati
dalle radiazioni
quindi io prendendo un vegetale come il
cavolo è stato contaminato da radiazioni
probabilmente nocive e pare che l'europa
sarebbe stata contaminata per vent'anni
da allora fino ad oggi da questo
deposito di queste scorie su sul
vegetale quindi nel mio lavoro ho
realizzato questa questa diciamo
immagine simbolo
ecco quindi diciamo con la spiegazione
queen dicevo prima se l'arte
effettivamente un lavoro non è un lavoro
ma è un modo di vivere proprio quindi
l'arte proprio praticamente nel non
detto e cercare di individuare quelli
che sono ovviamente le contraddizioni
c'è anche del parassitario ovviamente
l'artista le contraddizioni la cronaca e
la storia in cui attraverso l'uomo
quindi a volte può essere un'arte
edulcorati va può essere un'arte legata
alla cronaca le guerre non solo può
essere un'arte simbolica e può essere
un'arte tipicamente intellettualizzata
cioè legata esclusivamente a un'indagine
tra il filosofico e letterario e di
quelli che sono in confronti diciamo
universitari e ovviamente qui si si
separano le cose perché l'arte oggi
tende a essere sempre più spettacolare i
musei e gli spazi che accolgono le
grandi mostre tendono a diventare delle
ludoteche quindi luoghi d'incontro luogo
di divertimento in cui sia dei piccoli
che dei grandi come dire ci si diverte
all'interno dell'arte noto che l'arte
non debba essere divertimento però si
trasforma un pochettino quello che si
intendeva un luogo di riflessione che
non è un male perché magari giocando
ecco si tende si impara però oggi conta
molto fare i numeri veramente un
intellettuale o un artista un filosofo
di qualche anno fa vive già in un mondo
in un contesto in cui fa fatica a
identificarsi o accettarlo
purtroppo magari di risulta di avere un
confronto sempre più riduttivo e sempre
più chiuso in se stesso
anche perché le piattaforme come dicevo
prima da internet
e le modalità di comunicazione cambiano
e cambia anche il modo in cui si
usufruisce il discorso e discorso arte e
non soltanto arte
diciamo che il ridisegnare e riproporre
o anticipare perché un'arte troppo
d'anticipo rischia di non essere
compresa si rischia di parlare un po a
vuoto
un'arte diciamo di un anticipo di 5 6
anni poi in qualche modo essere vista
come diceva prima il signore di
schopenhauer che in un primo momento si
può essere derisi in un secondo momento
ostacolati e poi magari cercare di
essere imitati effettivamente la storia
di molti artisti questo magari non
capiti non capiti magari nella loro era
e poi magari riconosciuti diciamo e non
è né in un secondo momento
vorrei concludere magari soltanto con
una piccola riflessione su in realtà
dove la tecnologia ci ha portati fino a
oggi
adesso con queste molte tv private
effettivamente ci sono molti documentari
motivi scientifici storici e quindi sono
molto accattivanti no perché per chi è
così come dire insaziabile per la
conoscenza e c'è un termine in fisica
che si chiama termination shock io ho
trovato anche chiamato una mia mostrata
natale termination shock e termination
shock praticamente uno è una zona nello
spazio dove il mezzo interstellare
quindi il pulviscolo interstellare va
impattare col col mezzo interstellare
ben parlare col vento solare
il vento solare viaggia a una velocità
supersonica mentre il mezzo
interstellare viaggiano a velocità
supersonica quando queste due forze si e
si scontrano avviene lo shock
quindi il termination shock in questo
posto dove è collocato il termination
shock e dove è arrivato il voyager 1
questo cosa vuol dire che l'uomo con la
sua tecnica è arrivato col suo la sua
progettazione in quella zona li più o
meno da un da diciamo da un po di tempo
il voyager sta attraversando quel
territorio quindi noi effettivamente
come dire stiamo mandando una macchina
e quando la mia domanda è la mia cosa
andremo anche noi fisicamente quindi
effettivamente questo è un pochettino e
il motivo di perfezionarsi di essere più
di essere perfezionabile e
l'iperrealismo che l'artista tende ad
arrivare ad imitare l'arte e quindi alla
tecnica quella robotica e quella non
solo è sempre più vicino a imitare
quello che fa la natura però la domanda
è questa
l'arte poi deve superare e quindi la
scienza la natura o in qualche modo deve
soltanto renderla più perfezionabile
sempre che lo sia
grazie del vostro scorsa sera